salut aujourd'hui on va faire une
expérience exceptionnelle tous ensemble
vous demandez sûrement pourquoi notre
part en boudin se retrouve dans cette
situation il se le demande aussi face la
moitié de son visage de frein sauf si on
a mesuré cette planche avec les
contrôleurs de l'htc miles pour que dans
le jeu dié une planche en bois qu'ils
fassent exactement les mêmes dimensions
bon on aurait préféré que ce soit aussi
dans le jeu un paravent bouddha mais non
la particularité de cette poche en bois
c'est qu'elle sera à 160 m 2 an au
dessus du vide on va devoir marcher
dessus
sans tomber moi j'ai des petits
problèmes de pas de vertige mais la peur
du vide et ce papa rien voilà une
anecdote on enfile tout ça et on va voir
si c'est un truc de ouf ou pas ça se
trouve c'est trop de la merde cette
vidéo est nul à chier
voilà ça peut jamais bien se passer et
je répète c'est où j'ai eu qu'ils
allaient ressortir à son fils il était
pas trop tôt ok on n'a pas les années
dans une ville qui s'apparente à être
quelque chose en construction j'ai un
petit new york à tignes york fictif
réticences risma l'enseignement du jeu
il ya un [ __ ] ascenseur
on a fait ce qu'on va rentrer dans
l'ascenseur sont tombés à cause du câble
on va passer de tout et les capteurs du
coup puisque ce jeu est vraiment bien
fait acheter le planque
c'est parti enfin la joue bien quand il
ya un trou comme ça entre deux portes
fake je te jure que je rende pas
aucaigne on y est
ça c'est le paravent bouddha donc un mec
ça fout un peu le vertige et pas te
mentir
en plus ils ont bien fait en sorte que
des éléments qui pendent comme ça pour
te [ __ ] les jetons on et parlait déjà
il ya un blâme et des ailes et pas même
endroit des religieux ok ce parti
sa grâce de ouf ça vers la scène
tellement comique
[Musique]
bah voilà
bah voilà bah ouais c'est bien
franchement c'est cool mais en fait j'ai
tellement l'habitude à la réalité
virtuelle que tu vois je peux je peux
danser quoi je peux faire semblant
d'avoir peur ça ridicule je fais le mec
mais moi ça me fait un peu le vertige je
pense faudrait un truc qui est le long
de tes gens mais qui capte les
mouvements des jambes comme ça tu peux
tu as voulu me tuer donc tout à me tuer
doute halloween tu es là bref j'ai une
idée nous on va aller plus loin que le
marché chaussettes blanches tu vas
kiffer quand j'étais petit j'allais
souvent au cirque
aujourd'hui on va s'entraîner comme la
magie du cirque d'hiver tu sois en sûr
la catastrophe arrive et où ça va être
la catastrophe là
combien sur 20 18h [ __ ] je suis mais
je me suis pas et de planche et je vais
partir en beauté il ya des vidéos de
maicon ça qui font se base sur les toits
d'immeubles comme ça là qu'ils se
mettent en équilibre sur le rebord d'un
mec je veux faire partie de ces gens là
allez allez
la gymnastique est en moi je la sors mes
souvenirs remontent clément chimiques et
les boîtiers attention ok cette
expérience de la plaine chat j'espère
que ça vous a fait kiffer même s'il est
pas de saucisson fromage la pleine
charge
thibault avait raillé mme pelchat c'est
un cirque et ou du fromage à puce est là
vous vous dites que c'est fini que vous
avez ri ou pas vous vous apprêtez à ma
table pouce vert mais attendez regarder
jusqu'à la fin comme vous pouvez le voir
il ya plusieurs étages
il ya le fire beck ou en gros je vois
comment les pompiers ok on a une mission
à temps que moi j'ai cherché pas c'est
quoi ça je crois que c'est une grande
année je veux bien les pompiers il vous
faudra maintenant les faits apparaissent
partout dans la ville troublée et tard
les mayas pas de feu tu vois des feux
doit y a pas de feu et mpm pas de feux
tricolores d'ailleurs c'est pour te dire
ouais c'est cool alors ça c'est cool je
rêve
regarde moi ça va bientôt là bas je
tends l'atterrissage d'abord et montaise
aurait des effets tout à fait ce que
j'aimerais c'est un peu nul c nul comme
suit pas et je suis encore vouloir et je
pense pas la piscine flemme de l'écran
là paris mais si on réussit que la mort
on est les meilleurs et deux oiseaux
attention ça dégage la mouette foyer
nettoyer un abattoir des pigeons ça fait
la beauté paris finalement ol et les
quotas de police mec je rentre pas je ne
suis pas un super héros avec sais quoi
je vais faire comme ce que les espagnols
font qu ils sont un peu style et ils
vont se poser sur les toits il est troué
le toit le plus haut comme ça c'est
celui-là qui se posent dessus comme ça
and what the fuck paiement je me posais
sur cette grue comme si c'était
quelqu'un de très stylé et je vais
admirer un peu le monde qui m'entoure et
vous demandé dès mai la vidéo si ça vous
a plu et de vous abonner
si ça vous a vraiment plu à très bientôt
une prochaine vidéo tu as tout le monde
[Musique]
cette fois la plongée